[MUSIC PLAYING]
E JOHN FEIG: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Tools for Building
Better Smart Home Actions.
I'm John, I lead the technical
solutions engineering team
for smart home.
GAURAV NOLKHA:
I'm Gaurav Nolkha.
I'm a solutions
engineer on Smart Home
and a lead on Local Home SDK
that was announced yesterday.
E JOHN FEIG: Great.
And over the last
two years, we've
worked a lot of developers
building Smart Home Actions.
And based on what we've
learned from working with you,
we've put together some new
APIs, tools, and processes
which we're going to
discuss here today.
And don't forget
to use the hashtag
#AoGDevs to share what you learn
about Google Assistant at I/O.
So just to start off and remind
everybody what Smart Home is,
there's this great quote
from somebody on the team.
It's, "nobody likes
the light bulb
that asks too many questions."
And what this is about is just
that, Smart Home is kind of
really focused on providing
concise grammar that's
also unified and consistent
across different brands
so that you get you have
one way of interacting
with your devices, and one way
of talking to your devices.
And you can actually control
many devices at once.
So when I say,
turn on the lights,
it turns on the lights
in my living room.
Again, across brands.
It treats plugs and
switches the same as lights,
depending on the
name that I give it.
And because HomeGraph
understands room context,
types, and traits, it knows that
my Google Home is in the living
room and my lights are
in the living room,
and just to go ahead and turn
on the lights in that room
when I say, turn on the lights.
And you get all that
for free with Smart Home
when you do a Smart
Home integration.
You also get both a voice UI and
a graphical UI that we build.
And you also have routines
that you can set up
to do things like, if
you say good night,
you can have it turn off
the lights, lock your doors,
arm your security system.
And that's all powered by
HomeGraph State, which we'll
talk about a little bit later.
GAURAV NOLKHA: To get
started with Actions,
go to Actions on Google
console and this is your window
to configuring your Actions,
whether it's the conversation
Actions or Smart Home Actions.
You're going to
create a new project,
and if you're building
for a Smart Home Actions,
make sure to select Home
Control and Smart Home tile.
We've had some complaints
from developers
about the discoverability
of Smart Home Actions,
and since then we've improved
the experience on the console.
And you're going to
do two main things,
like provide the
fulfillment URL--
which points to
your server where
you're implementing
the smart home API.
And you're going to
configure the account linking
section, which is how--
because we use OAuth to do the
account linking between Google
Account and your account.
E JOHN FEIG: Great.
And just to give kind of a recap
of the architecture of what
a Smart Home
integration looks like,
this is a kind of a
helpful little visual here.
So when you talk to your
Google Assistant surface--
your phone, or your Google
Home, or your Google Nest hub--
you'll say something
like, turn on the lights,
that device will
send a message up
to the Assistant
servers, which does
the natural language
understanding and figuring out,
like, from Home Graph what
devices you're talking about.
And then it sends a
message to your cloud,
which is then responsible
for sending that message
down to the device to take
the action that you want.
And then your device will
respond back up to your cloud,
and then your cloud sends
the response to Google,
and then Google sends that
response down to the device
to speak out to the user if it
was a success or failure-- what
happened.
And this is broken into
three sets of APIs.
The first is account linking,
which is done with OAuth2--
you know, just the
standard OAuth2.
And the thing to keep in
mind here that's a little bit
different, is that you
are the OAuth provider
and Google is the client.
The next step is
a set of intents
that go from Google Assistant
to your cloud, which
are SYNC, QUERY, and EXECUTE.
SYNC is basically where
you have an opportunity
to tell Google about the
devices that the user has.
So what types they
are, what traits,
which is the functionality
that those devices enable.
QUERY is when Google asks what
the state of your device is
and you respond with
saying, the light's on,
or the temperature
is set to 65 degrees.
And EXECUTE is
basically Google asking
you to take some action on a
device-- turn the lights on,
set the temperature, turn on
the fan, something like that.
And then the last two
APIs that are part of this
are APIs that go from
your cloud to Google.
And those are Report
State and Request Sync.
Report State is when
you have the opportunity
to proactively tell Google what
the state of your device is.
And Request Sync is
when you tell Google
that the device list needs
to be updated for the user.
And we'll talk through what all
that stuff is in a little bit.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So in
addition to the cloud
part between assistant
and your server
to implement the Smart
Home API, yesterday
we announced Local Home SDK.
This SDK allows
you, as developers,
to run your JavaScript
on Google Home devices.
And this JavaScript
contains the business logic
to control your devices
and discover your devices
in the user's local network.
This local part allows us to
get faster execution and better
reliability for
the whole system.
Because if local part fails
for some reason, you do
have the cloud as the
fallback available.
E JOHN FEIG: Yeah.
The Local Home SDK stuff
is really exciting.
So here today, we're
going to talk about kind
of three sets of things.
So there's APIs,
tools, and processes.
So APIs that we're
going to talk about
are really here to help your
users have a better experience
with the Smart Home interaction.
The tools that we're
going to talk about
are to help you in
your development.
So things that might have been
a little difficult before or you
didn't know about,
hopefully these things
will make it a lot
easier as you're working.
And then the process that
we're going to talk about
is understanding the
submission process.
And so let's get
started with APIs.
We have a few sets of things--
account linking.
There's some new
stuff with account
linking that we'll talk about,
which is really exciting.
Request Sync, Report
State, that we
mentioned a little bit ago,
and then also some security
updates.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So let's
talk to account linking.
This is one of the
first interactions
your users have with Google
in terms of your Smart Home
Action.
So a few days ago, I was
going through this myself.
I will talk about that.
So let's look at the quick flow.
I opened the Google Home app,
and I selected the partner
devices that I was
setting up, and I
see the web view
where I am required
to enter the
credentials and I accept
the permission to allow Google
to control these devices.
After that happened,
your server, your app,
returns the code to Google.
And Google servers exchange
that with an access
and a refresh token.
That access and
refresh token is used
when Google's sends Sync,
Query, and Executing
intent to your servers later.
So a few days ago
when I was doing this,
I downloaded the manufacturer
app, I set up these lights.
After multiple screens,
I have this device set up
and I'm able to control it
using the manufacturer app.
And 15 seconds
later, I'm sweating.
Why?
I wanted to link these devices
to my Google Assistant,
and I saw this page to enter
the username and password,
and I had already forgotten.
Well, some of you will
say that, that's not me.
But we've seen our users
actually drop off on the Setup
page, and it's a friction.
Well the interesting thing
is, the other app is already
on my phone and I'm logged in.
So can we leverage that?
E JOHN FEIG: Yes we can.
Introducing App Flip,
which is coming soon.
This is a really interesting
way to do account linking.
And what we do is, instead
of launching into a web view
to do the authorization
for OAuth,
we actually use the
app that's already
installed on the user's phone.
So what happens is, you
start the Assistant,
you go through that
list of actions again
and you find the
one that you want.
And when the user clicks on
it, we do a couple of things.
First, we see if you've
registered your app for App
Flip, and then we look
to see if that app is
installed on the user's phone.
And if those things
are true, then we
can actually just launch
straight into your app
and allow you to
authenticate your user.
Hopefully the user
is already logged
into the app on your
phone, and you can just
use those credentials to go
get an authorization code
and send it back.
The other thing that
this is really great
for is, it helps
with the disclosures
and things like that in
the scope, to let people
know like what you're
giving access to Google for.
And then once you're ready, you
click the button in your app
and it goes back to Google.
And again, this just replaces
the authorization leg
of the OAuth flow.
The rest of OAuth
stays the same.
So once you get a token back--
so here, once you return
the authorization code back
to Google, we do the
server to server exchange.
And like I said, so this
is exactly the same flow.
The diagram looks the same.
The only difference
is that, instead
of launching out to the web,
we're working within your app.
And so you have a
little bit more control
in terms of how you want to do
that authentication, as well.
So how does this work?
We use Intents on Android, and
on iOS we use Universal Links.
And this is just the basic way
to do interapp communication
on these platforms.
And so let's look a
little bit of code.
For Android, Google will
send an intent into your app,
launching the intent with
StartActivityForResult, which
means that, basically, once you
finish there's an intent that
gets sent back to Google.
And so the intent
that goes to you
gets handled in your
activity onCreate method.
And there's some important
intent extras that come in.
So there's Client ID
and Optionally Scope.
And you'll want to pull
out at least the Client
ID to do a validation.
And what you can do is, you
can validate both the Client
ID as well as the
package signature
from the incoming intent.
And you'll want to do this
because you want to make sure
that it's actually
Google calling you
and not some random phishing
app that's installed.
And so once you've done that,
you verified that it's Google,
you can call your
off OAuth backend.
And you'll want to do this,
and send the Client ID along,
to make sure that there's a
record created in your backend
with that authorization code,
so that when Google does
the token exchange
later on there's
a valid code for this
user in your database.
And so once you've
done that, and you've
gotten a code back
from your server,
you can create a new
Intent that you're
going to send back to Google.
You'll add a couple extras.
One is Response Type, which
you set to Authorization Code.
And the other is the actual
authorization code itself.
You'll want to make sure
to set the result to OK,
and then you're to
launch back in to Google.
On iOS, its Universal Links, and
it is even more straightforward
just to look at just a
couple of links here.
So the first one is the link
that launches into your app
from Google.
So you own this Universal
Link and you'll register it
with Apple just like you do.
And there will be several
query parameters that come in.
The Client ID--
same as on Android--
Scopes-- which you set in the
actions of Google console--
the State-- which is a string
that you just respond back
the identical string when
you give your response--
and then a redirect URI--
that's the universal
link for Google
that you're going to use
to launch back to Google.
And here, instead of
a package signature,
you can actually validate
the redirect URI as well as
the client ID.
You know, again, do the
same validation on iOS
using those couple of things.
And then once you've
done that, you
can call your
OAuth backend again
with your user credentials
that are already
stored in the app, as
well as the Client ID.
Once you get an authorization
code back from your servers,
then you can respond
back to Google
using Google's URI that was
provided in the redirect URI.
And again, the authorization
code and the state.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So now we're
happy with those lights,
and we get new lights from
the same manufacturer.
And I go to the same app and
I set up these new lights.
And just like last
time, we do the Setup
and now I'm able to control
the lights from the app.
But the great thing was,
I am immediately also
able to control it
from Google Assistant.
How did that happen?
That brings us to Request Sync.
So when your cloud sees-- a
change in Users Devices List,
or if you add really new
capabilities to your devices,
you let HomeGraph know that,
for this particular user,
something has changed.
That's the requesting API.
And at that point,
HomeGraph calls back
the same Sync Intent that
happened the first time
the user had linked.
So the good effect
is, the user didn't
have to do any
account linking again.
And assistant now knows
about the new devices,
so the user can go and control.
And this really provides a
very good user experience
for your users
who actually chose
to buy new devices from you.
So let's look at the
code command equivalent
of what happens here.
It's very simple.
You let us know the
agent user ID that
is affected with the change
in the Device's List,
and you specify the
API key that you
get from Google Cloud console
and call the HomeGraph Request
Sync API.
And there.
E JOHN FEIG: Great.
And now let's talk a little
bit about Report State.
Report State, as
we mentioned, is
when you proactively send
the state of your devices
to Google.
So every time a user
switches on a light,
you send this API to
Google letting us know
that that light is turned on.
If the user changes
the thermostat,
you send that State.
And the State data in
HomeGraph is ephemeral.
And so why does
Google need this?
And the answer is
Touch Controls.
So we have smart displays
and the Google Home
app that have graphical
controls for your devices.
And basically, to be able
to draw that control,
we need to know what the State
is so that we can draw it
appropriately.
And the Report State
API gives us the State
that we need to be able to
draw accurate and responsive
controls.
Let's look at a
couple of examples.
So here we have the Google Nest
hub as well as the Home app,
and you can see some
controls getting pulled up.
These are two
different surfaces,
they're convenient in
different situations.
But both are showing
the ability to control
a group of devices which might
be even different brands.
And so this is a
really great way
to do interactions for users.
And what happens, though,
is that if you don't provide
the State via Report
State, instead of getting
the nice graphical control,
what the user sees immediately
is a spinning dial while
we query for the State.
And it's really kind of
a jarring experience.
And so implementing this
is fairly straightforward.
There's just a few steps
to get Report State working
that you need to do.
The first-- which is
just a one time thing--
is to go enable
the HomeGraph API.
And then you'll create a service
account key, which is just
a one time thing, again.
And then at runtime
in your service,
you'll generate a JSON
Web Token, or JWT,
which is a verifiable method
of representing claims securely
between two party servers.
And then you'll create a
Report State JSON payload
and you'll call the API.
Now let's walk through each of
these a little bit of detail.
So to enable the
HomeGraph API, you'll
just go to the Google Cloud
console, select your project,
and then under the APIs and
services, you'll go to Library
and search for HomeGraph
API and click Enable.
Pretty straightforward.
The next-- again, this
is just a one time
thing-- is you would generate
a service account key.
And here, again, in the
APIs and services section,
you'll dropdown to Credentials
from Library, where you were.
And you'll click the
Create Credentials button
and you'll just go through
the steps to create that.
We recommend JSON type because
it's a little bit easier
to work with.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So now that
your server has access
to your service
account key and we
have to call the repository
notification API to let
HomeGraph know of
this change in State.
We will need two things.
First is a token to
communicate with HomeGraph,
and second is the payload.
So let's look at the first one.
So to create the token for
Google to verify your service,
we need a few things.
First is iss.
This is a service account email
which you can get from the JSON
that you downloaded.
The scope and audience will
remain same, pretty much,
because you're calling
the HomeGraph API
and you need to get the token.
Secondly, iat, the current time
is what you will specify here.
And you have to make sure
that the expiry is typically
an hour from the current time.
And this is
specified in seconds.
Once you have this
information handy,
there are libraries available in
pretty much all the server site
languages that are out there.
So check out JWT.IO
for more information
about the libraries for
your specific platform
and framework.
And you should be able
to take this information
and generate the token.
And finally, you
make sure that you
sign this token with
the private key that's
in the service account JSON.
So now that we have the token,
let's look at the payload.
So when the device
changes state,
and it lets your cloud
know of this new state,
you're going to create
this JSON payload.
And you see here, we
have the agent user ID
for which this device list
has changed its state.
And then we have
two devices here.
The first one is
on, and it's online.
And the second one--
probably a lock or a door--
and it's locked.
So you specify this JSON.
And finally, let's
call the Report State
in notification API.
And let's take a look at this
in the form of a curl command,
which is very straightforward.
The token goes into the
authorization header
as a Bearer token, and the body
becomes the Report State JSON
payload that we just created.
And you make a simple post
called, to the HomeGraph Report
State and Notification API.
And that's it.
At that point, all your smart
displays, visual displays,
and Google Home app
should show you the latest
state for your devices.
E JOHN FEIG: All right.
So next we're going to talk
about enabling security use
cases for Smart Home
with Google Assistant.
How are we going to do that?
Well, we're going to two
factor authentication, or 2FA.
2FA is basically a
second factor validation,
something like a pin
or an acknowledgment.
And it's used to make sure that
the person making the request
is actually authorized to do so.
And so why is this important?
Well, we heard your
feedback and you
wanted to be able to enable
Smart Home on devices
like locks, or security cameras,
security systems, or even
windows.
We launched a couple of
new traits this week--
lock-unlock and
arm-disarm-- that 2FA
is really, really useful for.
And the neat thing is
that all of your devices,
any interaction for EXECUTE
and QUERY, can use 2FA.
So if you have something
that you want to protect,
your want to make sure that
there's an acknowledgment,
you can do that.
And the other thing
to keep in mind here
is that, for
pin-type protections,
you actually own the pin.
So it's owned in
your service, you
can change it as frequently
as you want-- even
on every interaction
if you really want to.
So let's look at a couple
of different examples of how
this works.
So the first is No
challenge, which is basically
the same is a normal
interaction where you say,
OK, G, turn on the lights.
And assistant says, OK,
turning on three lights.
The second is an Ack needed.
And this is where you might need
some sort of acknowledgment.
You just want to make
sure that this is really
what the user wants to do.
And in case, the users ask
you to heat up the living room
to 100 degrees.
Which your service might get
that request and say, like,
that's pretty warm.
That's really outside our range
of what we'd recommend a room
to be, but we can do that.
And so you might want an
acknowledgment here and just
ask the user, are you sure?
And the user says, yes, and then
you can go ahead and do that.
And finally, we have
Pin needed, which
is asking Google
to unlock the door.
And here we want a little bit
more than just a confirmation,
so we ask for a security code
and the user provides that.
And then once you have
a code that's correct,
they can go ahead
and unlock the door.
And you can actually see this
in practice in our sandbox
with a cookie jar that's
protected by two factor
authentication to
keep the kids out.
GAURAV NOLKHA: Yeah,
definitely check that out.
It's cooler than the
code, but the code
is very simple as well.
So let's take a look.
So typically, when the user
wanted to control a device,
we send an EXECUTE Intent
to your server, right.
And without two
factor authentication,
your server returns
a success if it's
able to control the device.
But for this case, if you wanted
to implement the two factor
authentication, you would
return an error back to Google
for that EXECUTE response.
And this error as the status.
And the error code will
be Challenge needed.
And one important
thing you're to specify
is which type of
challenge you need.
It could be Pin or
it could be Ack.
So at that point assistant
will announce it to the user
and either ask for
an Ack or a Pin.
And now Google calls another
EXECUTE intent to your server.
And in this case, the
pin will be specified
in the EXECUTE intent.
So pretty straightforward.
Pretty much exactly
how you do an EXECUTE
and Process and EXECUTE intent.
But this time it has the pin,
your server validates it,
and if it is a valid pin, takes
the action that user requested.
E JOHN FEIG: All right.
Let's move on to Tools.
So these Tools are
here to help you
in your development
of Smart Home.
And we developed a
lot of these, really,
based on our experience
supporting you
in your development
as well as feedback
that we've gotten directly.
And the first thing
we're going to talk about
is a brand new tool that is
called the Smart Home Test
Suite.
And this is something that
we very recently launched,
and it addresses
this major problem
that people have had
when wanting to go
live with their actions.
The end of development,
you're done,
you want to publish
it make it available,
which is that previously,
we required devices
to be shipped for certification.
And now we realize that this
is hard for a lot of people.
Shipping devices
is expensive, it's
easy to miss those
emails back-and-forth.
The process was a bit opaque
and there were sometimes
multiple rounds of testing.
And especially if
you're international
and had to deal with customs.
And so what we're
doing here is, we're
actually giving you
control over the process.
You can test from
your desk, there's
no need to ship devices.
And it helps to give
you clarity and insight
into the certification testing.
So how does this work?
Well, the basic flow
is that you will
start by developing an action.
You just kind of
need the bare bones
to make one thing work, right.
So you'll do OAuth,
SYNC, EXECUTE, and Report
State for at least making
sure that one thing
end-to-end works.
And then after
that, you'll account
link your developer account and
make sure that you can use it.
So just do a smoke
test, make sure
that you can turn on
your light or something.
Next, you'll set up a Google
Home right next your computer
and crank up your
speaker's volume,
or you can put headphones on it.
And the reason is because
the test tool actually
generates TTS.
It generates commands that
say, OK, G, turn on the lights.
And the Google will
pick it up and then
try to take that action.
So it's kind of a cool
end-to-end test like that.
And so then you can load
the tool and run it.
And you can actually
run this tool
as much as you want while
you're in development.
And it's great for
test-driven development
because we don't send the
results from the tool back
to Google until you're ready.
And then when you
are ready to launch,
you can use a form linked in
the Tool to submit your results.
So another thing that's
really cool about this
is that it's only
in the browser.
This is a browser-based tool.
It doesn't send
results to Google
until you submit that form.
And so with that, we do need a
couple of pieces of information
to make this run.
We'll request the
agent user ID so
that we can identify which
specific user to pick out
and the service account key.
And these two things are
needed for a HomeGraph API that
will allow you to pull
devices that you own,
and you own the service
to, out of HomeGraph.
And we basically use the same
mechanism for this test suite
as well as the another
tool that Gaurav
will talk about in a minute.
And once you've provided
those couple of things,
the project ID should just
get filled in automatically
if you provide a valid
service account key.
Next we do a HomeGraph
Sync, and we ask HomeGraph
to get that user's devices.
And in this case, we get
a light with the traits
on, off, and brightness.
And then once we have the
device, we can click Next,
and the tool will
just automatically
generate the test cases based
on the device types and traits
that you've synced.
Next you can see
it start running,
and it'll just speak
out the commands,
and it'll go to the
Google Home, and then
the whole thing will happen.
And you'll Report State
back, and we can pick up
those Reported State events.
And you can see the progress--
where it is in the test--
as well as in the
log area, you can
see if the tests are
passing or failing,
which is really helpful.
And then once you're done--
and if you have
any failures, you
can open up a spreadsheet
that gets generated,
and look exactly where, OK,
these tests were passing
and then this one
was a failure--
and see why it failed.
And so we tell you, here's
the results that we expected,
and here's what you
gave us, and that's
where the discrepancy
is, so that you
can very easily go and fix
that and rerun the test.
And then once you're
done with that,
you can just submit your results
in the form that's linked
and you're good to go.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So this is
great, because integration tests
can be hard.
And especially now
this involves voice,
your server, your devices.
So you really want to use that.
And I use that, personally,
for the new traits that I
am working with these days.
It's amazing.
Check it out.
So, OK, moving on to
Report State tool.
Now one of the things that John
mentioned about Smart Home Test
Suite is that it relies on
Report State working so it
can check the state properly.
But what if Report
State is not working?
So here's a tool that'll
help you do that.
So we again need the same two
key information-- the agent
user ID and the
service account key.
Based on this information,
we can query HomeGraph,
get the state of the
devices that HomeGraph sees,
and if there is a discrepancy
between what HomeGraph sees
and what your server is seeing,
some debugging may be in order.
So this is a tool that
gives you a view into what
HomeGraph is able to see.
After you fix the issues
with Report State,
you know, it should all
work with the GUI controls.
E JOHN FEIG: All right.
Next up is a tool
called StackDriver.
And StackDriver, as
some of you might know,
is actually just a
generally available tool,
provided by the
Google Cloud Platform,
that is for scalable logging.
But here we're going to
actually talk about how
we use it for Smart Home.
And one of the things that
we heard from developers
is, there's this
kind of frustration
around a lack of logs
and a lack of insight
into what's happening
on the Google side
if there's a failure.
And what we're doing with
StackDriver is providing
those assistant side logs so
that you can see if, you know,
you get an error TTS that
comes back from Google
once you've tried to take some
action, what actually happened.
And the other neat
thing about this
is that StackDriver
allows for integrations.
And so you can actually
create a service
where you can subscribe
to these log events
and have them sent straight
into your own logging service
so that you don't need
to go to multiple places
to look at logs.
You can also parse the logs
that are coming in for analytics
and write your own
metrics based on that.
So let's look at
how to enable this.
The first thing
you're going to do
is, you're going to go to
the Google Cloud console
and you're going to, again,
pick your Action there
as your project.
And then you're going
to open up the menu
and go to the logging
section, and it's under Logs.
Next, there's this
Resource Picker dropdown
that you'll select.
And when you click
that, you're going
to select the Google
Assistant Action.
Once you've selected
those things,
you should see logs coming up.
And here is actually
something that I
was working on a
couple of weeks ago
where I had backend failures.
And this is the
sort of thing that,
if you're using maybe an HDB
proxy like Nginx or Apache
in front of your service
to handle the web requests,
and then will forward on the
request to your service--
if you get a 500, it
might actually not
be getting forwarded
back to your service.
And so your Services Logs might
not have this failure in it.
And that's where StackDriver is
like really, really useful, is
you can see those failures
that maybe your service doesn't
log because it doesn't
get those requests.
Another example of
that might be if you
have auth failures, where
the credentials are expired
or maybe not existent
on the Assistant side.
Those will get logged
here too, and it'll
give you an indication that
there's an auth failure.
And like I said,
you can integrate
this using Google Cloud Pub/Sub
to have those StackDriver
events sent straight into
your own logging service
if you already have one.
And you can, again,
peg metrics based
on the various types
of failures that you
get to understand the
areas where you need
you might need improvement.
And we have this
great tool, that's
a sample on GitHub, that
really just walks you through
how to do this.
It walks you through how
to create an integration
with StackDriver and
then also to parse out
those logs for metrics.
And it's a Smart
Home focused example.
GAURAV NOLKHA: So
John just showed us
an error with Sync
Response on StackDriver.
So now how do you debug in case
you actually send a 200 back?
So you think your Synced
response is right,
but Assistant did not
like it and it showed
the user account linking error.
Sync Validator comes
in handy at that point.
So on our adaptive
documentation for Smart Home,
we have embedded a validator.
It's a simple input box where
you paste your Sync Response
and let the script tell
you if it sees any errors
with your Sync Response.
So like you see here, Fight
is not a valid device type.
It probably needed to be Light.
And Darkness is not a valid
trait, it should be Brightness.
It also tells you type errors.
So for example, the name in this
case should have been a string.
And once you fix
these Sync errors,
your account linking and
sync both happen to work.
And you know, it's a
better user experience
and you can fix
these things easily.
We've talked about a
lot of applets and tools
that you can leverage.
But what if you're just starting
with the Smart Home and API
and you want to create
your first action?
We're going to check
out the Codelab.
And you can actually do it
in the Codelab area right
after this talk, or you can
go home and check it out
on the web.
So the goal of this Codelab
is to create a virtual device
and then be able to control this
virtual device using Assistant.
So you're going to implement
the SYNC, EXECUTE, and QUERY
endpoint, and also Request,
Sync, and Report State.
So it's a complete package.
It's a gateway to get started
with the Smart Home API.
E JOHN FEIG: All right.
And now we're onto
the last section,
which is understanding
the process that we
use once you're ready to submit
your Action and publish it.
So let's talk about the
submission process a little bit
and clear up kind
of what happens,
so that you understand
what's going on when
you click that Submit button.
And we're also making
some improvements
to make this easier and smoother
for you throughout the process.
And so here's how to
submit and what happens.
The first thing
you're going to do
is submit passing results
in the Smart Home Test Suite
using the form that's
linked in the tool.
So just really simple--
make sure you're
passing the Test Suite.
Second, is that you're going
to go and fill out company
and branding information in
the Actions on Google console.
Just make sure that you've
filled out everything
that we asked for,
and it will make
things go quite a bit faster.
The next move over
to the Google side--
and so this might actually
be a bit of a back-and-forth.
We might reach out
to you with things
that need to be updated
and stuff like that.
And those would come
out of two things.
So there's a functional
certification
that happens where we review
the results that you submitted
for the Smart Home
Test Suite as well as
a policy review that
happens to make sure
that you're in compliance
with all of our policies.
And then once you
pass those two things,
you're ready to go live.
And we have some tips that
we've kind of collected
over the couple of years about
how to make this as smooth
as possible and to kind
of avoid back-and-forth.
And the first thing that's
really, really important
is to use the appropriate
types and traits.
So this is something that we
see as kind of a common issue.
And we see things like
using on-off as opposed
to start-stop.
And there are cases where you
might have a robot vacuum,
and Start Vacuuming is a
much more natural grammar
to say than Turn On the Vacuum.
Another one to keep in mind
is like temperature control
versus temperature setting.
One of them is for
thermostats, and the other one
might be for your oven.
And then finally,
also making sure
that you're using a two
factor authentication where
appropriate.
So you know, if it's a lock,
security system, you really
want to make sure
that you're using 2FA.
The next thing is
again, just making
sure you're passing
the Test Suite.
Not a lot to say there, but
definitely run the Test Suite
as frequently as you like.
The next thing is to make sure
that your descriptions match
the locales.
So let's say that you're ready
to launch your Smart Home
Action, and you're
shipping devices in Japan
and you want to launch
your Action there.
That's great.
Make sure that, instead of
submitting a description that's
in English, you
submit one that's
also in Japanese if you're
selecting Japan as a locale.
The next is making
sure that you're
just in compliance with all
of our policies for AoG.
And then you'll
want to make sure
that you supply a
valid privacy policy
for each supported language.
So again, you've submitted
a Japanese description,
you're going to submit
a privacy policy that's
written in Japanese.
The next thing is to make
sure that you've implemented
all of our APIs including Report
State, Request Sync, and Query.
These are really critical,
and in fact the Test Suite
won't work well if you don't
implement these things.
It won't work at all if you
don't implement Report State.
You'll want to make sure that
account linking is working.
And this might seem obvious,
but once you launch,
your users are going to
try to do account linking
and start interacting with you.
And if account
linking doesn't work,
they won't be able to do that
and you'll have zero users.
You'll want to make sure that
the cloud to cloud latency
is consistently under 900
milliseconds, which is just
kind of where we really find
it to be very noticeable
if there's cloud latency.
When you say, Turn
on the Lights,
and then it takes more than
a second for that to happen,
it's pretty noticeable.
The next is to make sure
that the authorization grant
in your OAuth flow
grants permission
to Google and not
something else.
We don't want to see
permissions granted
to Google Assistant, or
Google Home, or Nest,
or anything else-- just Google.
And finally, make sure that
the icon that you provide
is 144x144 circular
with a white background.
GAURAV NOLKHA: Cool.
And if you are a
maker, or someone who's
just doing this
for fun, definitely
add the Assistant
and the voice control
to your devices in
your fun project
and you don't have to
worry about the approval.
So use it.
And then finally, all the things
that we've talked about today
and the documentation for
this lives under our docs
at developers.googl
e.com/actions/smarthome.
And it lives inside
Actions Google and click
under the Smart Home section.
And this will guide you through
the APIs, and the tools,
and everything that we
just talked about today.
So finally, thank you
very much for coming here.
Last two years has been
a thrilling ride for us
on Smart Home, and we've worked
with many of you in the room
and outside this room.
And we really thank you for
all the feedback on the APIs,
on the tools, and our
processes that you provided
that has helped us improve
our tools and all the APIs
and processes.
And we can't wait to see what
you guys do with these tools
and the actions you build.
Thank you.
E JOHN FEIG: Thank
you for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]